we had a really tough year this year the
Yukon river is kind of our lifeblood
here and we no longer have it as an
option for getting food so we're relying
on getting moose bears and Caribou we
had no luck getting a moose this year
the Caribou have not shown up in our
country until just recently so Denise
and I are on the
hunt there's fresh Caribou tracks I'm
seeing a lot of sign today we just had a
fresh snow last night so anything that
we see out on the trail right now is
going to be fresh so this is pretty
exciting it looks like there's at least
two maybe three small band small bands
are harder to hunt they're a lot more
wary so I'm hoping I can kind of come up
on some that are maybe grazing and if we
can do that I might have a chance of
getting a little bit of meat we'll just
going to keep poking our way up River
and see if we can't find one get a
shot I'm at a big disadvantage right now
we're on a small river that has a lot of
bends and so you come up on them before
you can really see them to stalk them so
it's really
challenging
the animals notice absolutely everything
they're extremely in tune the only
chance we're going to have when we're on
snow machines is to come up to a corner
and get a Long View down where they
haven't had a chance to hear us
yet
[Music]
so I just ran into a bunch of caribou
came out this way and then they went
back this
way they heard Denise and I before we
could get the machine
stopped looks like I scared out of those
Caribou there's a bunch of them well not
a bunch it looks like maybe five or six
or whatever nice a few more seconds and
maybe would have got a shot off it would
have been an awful long shot though it's
really hard to hunt Caribou in this kind
of country because it like they're so
fast yeah you know 30 seconds and
they're in this brush and you'll never
see them so let's keep keep going
[Music]
yep